نقلت وكاله رويترز عن مصادر فيتاجون
واستخبارات اسرائيليه قولهم ان الحرس
الثوري الايرانيه كان يستعيد لشن هجوم
بمسيرات على سفن لاسرائيل في الخليج
نقلت انيرك تايمز عن مسؤولين استخباريين
غربيين ان الجيش الامريكي والاستخبارات
الاسرائيليه حذرا من ان الحرس الثوريه
الايراني يحضر لهاجمات بمسيره على سفر
تجاريه مدنيه اسرائيليه تبحر من منطقه
الخليج وبحر العرب وقالت الصحيفه ان
البحريه الامريكيه ارسلت الغواصه فلوريدا
الحامل لصواريخ موجهه الى منطقه الشرق
الاوسط بعد يوم واحد من هذا التحذير وقلم
مسؤولون امريكيون ان الهدف من نشر الغواصه
الامريكيه هو ردع ايران والحفاظ على
استقرار احد اكثر الممرات الشحن ازدحاما
في العالم